HER EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH HHS
ALEX.
BUT FIRST THE BIG NEWS OF THE
WEEK.
PROOF THAT TARIFFS WORK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP THEN TARIFFS ON
MEXICO AND THE LEADER CAME TO
NEGOTIATE AND WE GOT CONCRETE
RESULTS.
EVEN THE WALL STREET JOURNAL HE
WAS GENERALLY INDISPENSABLE AND
BRILLIANT EDITORIAL PAGES WERE
AGAINST TARIFFS RECOGNIZE THE
PRESIDENT'S ACHIEVEMENT "IN THE
COURSE MR. TRUMP MANAGED TO GET
MEXICO TO AGREE TO DO THINGS,
MONTH AGO WOULD'VE SEEMED
UNLIKELY.
MILITARIZE MEXICO'S CRACKDOWN ON
MIGRANTS BY DEPLOYING GUARD
TROOPS AND STANDING THE MARINE
FOR SEVEN SEEKERS.
THE ANATOMY OF THIS LATEST TURF
DISPUTE TELLS US A LOT ABOUT
POLICY, POLITICS AND GOVERNMENT.
SHOULD LEARN.
ONE AGREES WITH THE CRISIS AT
THE CELEBRITY.
TWO WEEKS AGO 1000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WALKED INTO THE
COUNTRY.
AN APOSTLE.
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM IS NOT BROKEN
BUT FOR ALL PRACTICAL PURPOSES
IT DOES NOT EXIST.
BUT THERE IS ONE PERSON IT SEEMS
WHO'S ACTUALLY TRYING TO FIX IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THAT IS WHAT HE RESORTED TO THE
CHARACTER.
IT'S A NEW APPROACH AND OF
COURSE THE ESTABLISHMENT LOST
HER MIND.
>> A 5% TARIFF TO STOP
IMMIGRATION DOESN'T MAKE SENSE?
>> DOESN'T MAKE SENSE,.
>> PART OF WHAT THEY'RE ASKING
THEM TO DO IS VIOLATE
INTERNATIONAL LAW.
>> IF WHEN YOU GROW UP YOU WANT
TO RATTLE THE FINANCIAL MARKET
THREATENED TARIFFS AGAINST
MEXICO.
>> NOPE AND SPRING BUT I DON'T
THINK KIDS ARE WATCHING YOUR
SHOW.
THE REPUBLICAN ESTABLISHMENT
HEATED INTO.
>> TARIFFS ON THE OTHER HAND
WOULD BE A MASSIVE TAX.
>> UNDERSTAND THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS FRUSTRATED WITH THE DEMOCRATS
REFUSING TO DO THE JOB OR TO DO
ANYTHING TO FIX THE CRISIS.
THAT BEING SAID, THIS IS THE
WRONG SOLUTION.
>> THERE'S NOT MUCH SUPPORT IN
MY CONFERENCE FOR TARIFFS.
THAT IS FOR SURE.
STEVE: IDEOLOGICAL, DOMESTIC,
HERE FIRST, THE POLITICIANS AND
THE MEDIA SHOULD BE MORE
OPEN-MINDED GIVING NEW IDEAS AND
NEW APPROACHES A CHANCE INSTEAD
THE WAY THEY WERE TALKING,
TARIFFS ON MEXICO WOULD BE THE
END OF THE ECONOMY.
THEY LET IDEOLOGY GET IN THE WAY
OF THE FACTS EVEN THOUGH MEXICO
IS THE BIGGEST TRADING PARTNER
AND PLAYED A PART IN OUR
ECONOMY, IMPORTS FROM MEXICO
MAKE UP 1.8% OVER ECONOMY.
IN EXPERTS TO MEXICO ARE EARNING
1.4%.
THE CRITICS DIDN'T EVEN LOOK AT
IT AS A PRACTICAL POLICY
QUESTION, THEY JUST SAY TARIFFS
ARE BACK.
IT WAS THE SAME THING WITH THE
DOGS ON TV CROSSING THE LINE
ABOUT AMERICAN CONSUMERS.
>> IS GOING TO COST MEXICO, IT
WILL COST CONSUMERS, TARIFFS ARE
TAXPAYERS.
>> THERE'S NO WAY TO DESCRIBE IT
THEN OVERWHELMING NEGATIVE
PERMITTING BUSINESSES AND
CONSUMERS PRAY.
>> EVEN I KNOW TARIFFS ARE A TAX
DEBT PAID BY THE CONSUMER.
>> IT IS FOUND TO BE FALSE.
HANG ON A SECOND, PRESIDENT
TRUMP HAS BEEN INTRODUCING
TARIFFS FOR OVER TWO YEARS AND
GOING BACK FROM 2017 WHEN
TARIFFS ON LUMBER IMPORTS WITH
LESS THAN 24%.
WE'VE HAD TARIFFS ON CHINA,
CANADA.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO CONSUMER
PRICES IN THAT TIME.
WE HAVE AN ACTUAL MEASURE AND IS
CALLED INFLATION.
THE AVERAGE INFLATION FOR 2016
WAS 2.1%.
2172.4% IN 2019 SO FAR 1.7.
SECTION GOING ON.
COMPANIES DO NOT SIT THERE AND
TAKE IT WHEN TARIFFS ARE
IMPOSING WE RESPOND.
ONE PERSON THAT SEEMS TO GET
THAT,.
>> THE COMPANIES WANT TO MOVE
BACK INTO THE UNITED STATES.
>> HE IS RIGHT, COMPANIES ARE
MOVING AWAY FROM COUNTRIES BY
THE TERM TARIFFS ESPECIALLY
CHINA.
AND IN A BIG WAY, RECENT SURVEY
BY COMPANY SHOWED 25% OF
CORPORATE EXECUTIVES WILL BE
REDIRECTED THE INVESTMENT OUT OF
THE AREA AND 42% ARE EXPECTED TO
SOURCE THE RAW MATERIALS FROM
SOME PLACE ELSE.
SOME OF THE COMPANIES LEAVING
CHINA ARE ELECTRONICS, AND GO
PRO.
LOOK AT THIS QUOTE FROM THE CEO
CONTROL TECH, A COMPANY USED TO
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN CHINA.
>> WE DESIGNED CHINA OUT.
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT FOR A
MOMENT.
THAT IS A MASSIVE POLICY LESSON.
THE AMERICAN MANUFACTURE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP COMES IN AND YOU
SEE IMMEDIATE PRIVATE SECTOR
RESPONSE AND WE DESIGNED CHINA
OUT.
TRUMP'S TARIFFS DERIDED BY THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF TURNING OUT TO
BE THE MOST CONSEQUENTIAL AND
POSITIVE ECONOMIC POLICY
MECHANISM WE HAVE SEEN IN
DECADES.
HIS DOCTORS COMPANIES MOVING OUT
OF CHINA, WE'VE SEEN THEM MOVE
BACK TO AMERICA JUST AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID, THEY HAVE THE
LATEST EXAMPLE.
ANOTHER THING ESTABLISHMENT
GENIUSES SAY YOU SHOULD NOT
METAL UP WITH IMMIGRATION POST.
CHUCK GRASSLEY SAID TREE POLICY
ARE SEPARATE ISSUES.
ANOTHER REPUBLICAN WAS REPORTED
SAYING THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS TRYING TO USE TARIFFS TO
SOLVE EVERY PROBLEM BUT HIV AND
CLIMATE CHANGE.
BUT WHY NOT?
BY THE WAY THIS IS THE LAST TIME
I WILL HAVE A CHINESE DICTATOR,
HE SAID WHO CARES,
BLACK-AND-WHITE AS LONG AS IT
CATCHES LIGHT.
AS WE SEEN FOR THE MEXICO
TARIFFS IT DID.
VERY QUICKLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S USE OF TARIFFS
WAS ACCRETE TO SUCCESSFUL
POLICYMAKING, THIS IS ALL
POINTED AT TRUMP TO DO THINGS
DIFFERENT, TO STAND UP TO THE
USELESS BUREAUCRATS AND THEY SAY
BOG DOWN AND I IMAGINE THE
MEETINGS ON THIS, BUT THE
PRESIDENT HAS HAD THE LAST THREE
MONTHS, I'VE BEEN IN THE PULSING
MEETINGS.
YOU CANNOT DO THAT
MR. PRESIDENT, WILL UPSET THE
CHINESE.
MR. PRESIDENT IF YOU DO THAT
WILL GET PUSHBACK.
>> THAT JUST GIVES HIM A BIT
MORE TIME TO WORK SOMETHING OUT
MR. PRESIDENT.
TALK ABOUT NERVOUS NANCY PELOSI.
BEHIND GOVERNMENT MACHINE
NERVOUS NANCY.
USUALLY POLITICIANS GIVEN AND
I'VE SEEN OVER AND OVER AGAIN
AND THAT'S WHEN NOTHING HAPPENS.
TRUMP IS DIFFERENT, I HAVE HAD
ENOUGH OF ALL THE NEGATIVE CROP
AND I WANT ACTION,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND RESULTS.
YES, THAT IS WHAT AMERICANS
VOTED FOR.
THE ESTABLISHMENT IDIOTS WHO
CONDEMN HIM FOR, THEY CARE ABOUT
DRILL NOT SUBSTANCE AS LONG AS
YOU BEHAVE THE RIGHT WAY, SAY
THE RIGHT THINGS, DO IT THE
WEIGHTS BEEN DONE, THEY LOVED
OBAMA BECAUSE HE WENT ALONG WITH
IT AND BEHAVE THE WAY THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF SHOULD IN TRUMP
DOES NOT.
THAT IS NOT MAKING THAT IT MAKES
HIM GOOD.
THE ESTABLISHMENT IS OBSESSED
WITH TRUMP AND HIS TWEETS.
BUT HE IS OBSESSED DUE IN YOUR
LIFE.
THE FINAL LESSON OF THIS WEEK IS
WHAT HAS NOT HAPPENED.
THE PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT BE
HAVING THE PRESSURE IS MEXICO
THE WAY HE DID.
IT SHOULD BE OUR OWN GOVERNMENT,
NOT THE FOREIGN GOVERNMENT THE
FIXES ARE IMMIGRATION CRISIS IN
HERE RETURNED TO THE DEMOCRATS.
ISN'T IT SICKENING TO SEE THEM
ON THEIR HIGH HORSE WITH TRUMP'S
BORDER POLICY.
>> HE HAS TO DECIDE WHO WE ARE
MORALLY AND WHO WE SAY WE ARE TO
THE WORLD.
>> IS IN IMMORALITY, IT'S NOT
WHO WE ARE AS A NATION.
>> NOT WHO WE ARE, WHO ARE YOU
NANCY, YOU'RE THE ONE STANDING
IN THE WAY OF THE CHANGES THAT
WOULD HELP PREVENT.
LET BORDER OFFICIALS DETAIN
FAMILIES OVER 20 DAYS, LET
CHILDREN CLAIM ASYLUM IN THEIR
HOME COUNTRY IN THE BE REUNITED
WITH THE FAMILIES THAT EARLY
HERE.
CHANGE ASYLUM SOCIAL TO THE
INCREDIBLE THING INTERFERE TAX
AND GETTING ASYLUM.
IT DOES HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE WALLS THAT YOU DEMOCRATS YOU
HATE BUT OF COURSE WE NEED THAT
TOO.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE BLOCKING
COMMON SENSE AND IMMIGRATION
REFORM PURELY TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS.
IT'S YOU NANCY PELOSI WHO'S
EXPLOITING DESPERATE MIGRANTS TO
POLITICAL GAMES, THE YOUNGER
ALSO SAID ON THE DANGEROUS
JOURNEY, THE FAMILIES THAT ARE
SEPARATED BECAUSE OF THE BROKEN
SYSTEM.
IT IS ON YOU NANCY, NOTHING IS
EVIL BUT YOU.
THE PERSON WHO IS STANDING IN